[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con el mundo
observa con preocupación lo que ocurre
en india con récord de casos y muertes
diarias ante la extrema situación en
eeuu el reino unido francia y alemania
prometieron enviar ayudas de urgencia
como ya lo hizo reino unido- mientras
que cientos de cuerpos cada día son
cremados de manera masiva debido a la
alta tasa de mortalidad que registra la
nación asiática por el virus para hablar
de esta compleja situación saludo en
este momento a daniel lópez acuña médico
epidemiólogo y también ex director del
departamento de acción sanitaria en
situación de crisis de la organización
mundial de la salud gracias por estar
aquí con nosotros en 5 minutos con
doctor el director general de la omct
aseguró que la situación en índia es más
que desgarradora como las imágenes
también que hemos visto y que la
organización está haciendo todo lo
posible proporcionando equipos y
suministros incluidos miles de
contenedores de oxígeno y quiero
preguntar qué es lo que hace que esta
situación sea tan dramática y además le
pregunto si las ayudas anunciadas serán
suficientes
bueno es una combinación de factores que
tenemos que tomar en cuenta lo primero
es estar muy conscientes de que ha
surgido una variante la variante de la
india que tiene una doble mutación que
la hace más contagiosa más severa pero
también que amenaza con hacerla escapar
de la acción de las vacunas es decir que
las vacunas no tengan la suficiente
eficacia ante esta variante esto por
supuesto en un escenario de alta pobreza
alta concentración de población en las
ciudades densidad de población y
demografía de gran asignación en la
india- genera un número incontrolado e
incontrolable de episodios de kobe 19 y
esto evidentemente colapsa la atención
sanitaria además el sistema sanitario de
la india no es un sistema de acceso
universal para toda la población hay
muchas deficiencias en la
infraestructura básica en el
equipamiento en el oxígeno en los
medicamentos y por si fuera poco
a pesar de que india es un país que
produce vacunas para la exportación a
otros países del mundo asociadas
especialmente a la patente de
astrazéneca
la india no está teniendo una alta
cobertura de vacunación de su propia
población las vacunas se producen pero
se van a otro lugar y esto nos está
mostrando las grandes inequidades que
enfrentamos en la distribución de las
vacunas y en el acceso a las vacunas en
el ámbito mundial doctor usted decía
algo que era muy preocupante y es debido
a esta variante india las vacunas no van
a tener tanta efectividad entonces qué
va a pasar con esa población y qué va a
pasar con la gente que ya que ya está
vacuna podría enfermarse de gravedad
podría lo mejor llegar también a estas
unidades de cuidados intensivos hoy cuál
es la tasa de efectividad de las vacunas
al frente a esta variante india
está todavía estableciéndose cuál es la
diferencia en efectividad de las vacunas
con respecto a esta variante pero
evidentemente y esto no es sólo con la
variante indie esto no lo vamos a tener
que enfrentar mientras siga adelante la
pandemia y no la frenemos con suficiente
velocidad con una vacunación acelerada
en el mundo entero no sólo en los países
occidentales vamos a tener el
surgimiento de variantes que pueden
amenazar la seguridad que puede otorgar
la vacuna o las vacunas entonces la
situación que tenemos es que si esta es
una variante que escapa a las vacunas se
se tendrá que desarrollar una
combinación de vacuna con esta variante
que obligará a nuevas vacunaciones
protección adicional a un ciclo de
vacunación que esperemos no tenga que
ser como el de la gripe estacional cada
año pero el escenario que tenemos si es
una gran variación del virus y de una
necesidad de que la vacuna se vaya
ajustando
cuando las cepas o las variantes no sean
sensibles a estos bajones ahora usted
está miento decía india es uno de los
países más poblados del mundo por lo que
también resulta difícil a las
autoridades controlar los aforos evitar
que la gente se aglomera están a filas
para ser vacunadas que podría ser el
gobierno indio para evitar más contagios
muy brevemente por favor que ya se me
acaba el tiempo
bueno las medidas que se tienen que
tomar en todo el mundo para reducir las
interacciones sociales y la movilidad
restricciones en términos de viajes para
que quienes procedan de la india hacia
países con riesgos menores o simplemente
sin presencia de esta variante check
éste tengan una cuarentena que permita
identificar casos proteger y evitar una
diseminación de una variedad doctora
doctor gracias por su tiempo por estar
aquí con nosotros en france 24 ustedes a
mí gracias continúen con nosotros
[Música]